so ever since donald trump left the
white house there's been a lot of talk
about how he might monetize his brand
you know a lot of former presidents
write books or start giving speeches but
everyone sort of assumed that donald
trump was going to do something bigger
and we got an indication of what that
was going to be a couple of months ago
when they announced the formation of the
trump media and technology group it's
big tech and all of those on the left
for so long sean have been saying well
if you don't like the rules that we
really enforce only one way on our
platforms go create your own and so we
did just that
now this is a company that doesn't
really do much yet they don't have
any business you can't buy anything from
them but it's more of an idea
and they've decided to merge that idea
with a pile of cash
and then have those merged companies
trade publicly and right now based on
how the pilot cash is trading
investors are assuming that this idea is
worth about eight billion dollars so
that would make it an extremely valuable
media company and certainly it indicates
that there are a lot of people who are
excited about what this could become
now obvious question how much of this
stuff is actually going to be donald
trump's so we don't actually know yet
what percentage of the trump media and
technology group trump owns currently
there are some indications that he might
own a majority of it if he does own a
majority of it and if the share price
stays at that current level
then you're looking at at least three
billion dollars for donald trump now to
put that in perspective
donald trump over his entire life
has been accumulating assets he was
receiving you know a thousand dollars a
month from his father when he was three
years old and he's been piling on ever
since
over all those years
he's amassed about two and a half
billion dollars
so right now investors are suggesting
that if he owns more than half of this
of this company that's merging with a
spec then that asset which is not an
operating company you can't buy anything
from it it's just an idea that asset is
worth more than everything else that he
spent his entire life piling up and
that's when the numbers start to get a
little bit head scratching and you have
to wonder whether people ultimately are
going to say you know what this thing
isn't actually worth quite as much as we
think it might be worth and if that
happens then some of these numbers are
going to fall apart